invité du 19/20 donc patrick pas de
patrick dils
bonsoir soi et merci d'être venus en
priorité sur le plateau du 19-20 vous
allez retrouver la liberté et votre
honneur depuis six mois maintenant
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus agréable
pour vous et qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
difficile le plus agréable c'est de
retrouver mes proches mes parents mon
frère pour aller prendre dans mes bras
et puis bien de retrouver mon honneur
parce que c'est quand même une bataille
de 15 ans et quelle bataille
maintenant qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
difficile je dirais bien c'est de faire
face au génie aux administrations pour
ba être comme tout le monde dans la
légalité
c'est à dire avoir sa carte d'identité à
voir enfin préparer les papiers pour le
permis de conduire enfin les choses
simples la vidéo aux yeux de
l'administration existe vous êtes le
détenu deals voilà ne plus être un
numéro
franchement est ce que est ce que vous
avez tout de suite su quoi faire de
votre liberté ou es ce que vous avez été
un peu désorienté absolument pas j'ai
tout de suite su quoi faire parce que
j'ai pas peur de monter en prison j'ai
peut-être pas vraiment fait des études
mais j'ai toute ma détention travail et
donc travaillé quelques jours après ma
libération
pour moi c'était c'était logique c'était
normal parce que je voulais plus
simplement comme tout le monde
donc j'ai travaillé et j'ai pris des
vacances après pour bien montrer à tous
ceux qui ont cru en moi et ben que le
patrick dils qu'ils étaient en prison
c'est le même qui est sorti et c'est le
même il n'y en a pas deux des patries
disent y'a pas de clown
patrick dils il est là aujourd'hui en
face de vous il veut vraiment réussir sa
vie alors vous vous avez parlé un petit
peu de vos premiers jours de travail
vous avez presser un peu plus de deux
mois à paris et franchement ça n'a pas
dû être très facile j'imagine que le
choc
le passage entre une cellule de 15
mètres carrés et la vie à paris ça a dû
être assez assez dure pour vous ça a été
terrible parce que les noirs
je passais au melon c'est à dire que
j'allais vraiment dans la capitale ce
qui est plus grande ce qui ce qui
bougent le plus
donc je compare un petit peu avec mes
mots je dirais la capitale à une
fourmilière
les gens ne prennent plus le temps de
vivre les gens me prennent prennent plus
le temps de d'apprécier les choses
simples de la vie et je crois
malheureusement il faut on est privé
pour vraiment se rendre compte que la
liberté mais c'est cesca plus important
vous avez acquis en fait paradoxalement
une une philosophie en prison pour après
quoi pour un prêt vous avez entièrement
raison je dirais que j'ai fait l'école
la plus dure 1 école de la vie la prison
el mar en lui aussi elle m'a forgé un
caractère et je crois que après avoir
vécu ces quinze dernières années
derrière les barreaux
je suis prêt à tout il ya plus rien qui
peut le faire peur alors justement vous
dites l'école la plus dure vous avez
écrit un livre qui donc sera publié
jeudi prochain j'ai l'impression que
vous avez écrit un livre comme on tourne
une page un petit peu comme si vous
vouliez tourner la page
pourquoi est ce que vous avez décidé
d'en siffler de tout raconter y compris
les humiliations les plus difficiles de
vos codétenus
mais cela à partir du moment où j'ai
terminé à le dire à la cour d'assises je
savais que on allait de nouveau mort
parler un jour ou l'autre
alors j'ai pris mes devant j'ai dit bon
bain puisque j'avais l'intention déjà
avant de sortir de sa part et un livre
je me suis dit allez on balance tout en
ignorant dit tout et puis qu'on laisse
tranquille les gens veulent savoir
et ben qu'ils achètent le livre et ils
seront mais il faut peut venir me
demander oui qu'est ce que tu as vécu en
prison comment ça s'est passé
maintenant il ya un livre qui est très
bien fait et tout cas un pansement
l'intérieur et visite à la fin de ce
livre que maintenant votre rêve le plus
important c'est de retrouver la napoule
ce qui est plus important pour moi parce
que le côté célébrités d'ailleurs c'est
un mot que je n'aime absolument pas
puisque je ne suis pas une vedette je
suis pas une célébrité
juste une victime du système judiciaire
alors effectivement il ya des gens qui
vont mettre une vie pour devenir célèbre
et moi je crois je vais mettre le
restant de mes jours pour essayer skins
sera loin d'être évident de retomber
dans l'anonymat
patrick dils merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le plateau du 19-20 rappel le titre
de votre livre qui sort donc jeudi en
libre
lee je voulais juste rentrer chez moi et
c'est édité chez michel lafon dire merci